Es könnte alles so schön sein es gibt nämlich eine total simple und schlüssige erklärung für die dunkle materie
demnach existiert die dunkle materie als solche gar nicht und gibt uns damit auch nicht mehr
das rätsel auf aus was sie besteht sondern sie besteht aus etwas was wir bereits gut kennen nämlich
schwarze löcher allerdings gibt es jetzt eine neue studie die diese hypothese einen strich durch die rechnung macht klick zum science fiction
täglich science videos abonniert den kanal dann verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
Es wäre so schön simpel was wäre wenn das ganze universum voller schwarzer löcher wäre viel mehr
als wir zur zeit vermuten was wäre wenn der
hauptbestandteil des
weltalls schwarze löcher werden dann könnten sie ja die dunkle materie sein warum ganz einfach die dunkle materie ist ja mit ihrer gravitation
dafür verantwortlich dass sich galaxien anders verhalten als sie würden wenn sie nur aus materie bestehen würden die
sternsysteme am äußeren rand bewegen sich viel schneller als erwartet
als wenn nur die sichtbare materie vorhanden wäre aber genau dieses verhalten
müsste nicht die dunkle materie sondern könnten schwarze löcher genauso verursachen sie kennen wir schon und wir wissen sehr genau was sie
verursachen und nämlich genau das und wenn man sich auf wikipedia in den ersten satz zur beschreibung der dunkle materie
ansieht dann ist das eine absolute erleuchtung dunkle materie ist eine
postulierte form von materie die nicht direkt sichtbar ist aber über die gravitation wechselwirkt und auf was trifft genau diese beschreibung zu
exakt auf schwarze löcher das würde auch erklären warum die seltsamen teilchen der dunklen materie nie gefunden wurden alexander
kaczynski vom goddard space flight center der nasa hat eine studie dazu veröffentlicht seine these in den ersten sekunden unseres universums
haben sich als erstes die schwarzen löcher
so genannte primor ideale schwarze löcher gebildet sie bilden die dunkle materie und haben überhaupt dafür
gesorgt dass die materie die nicht in sie gestürzt ist sterne
systeme und galaxien bilden konnte sie waren nämlich eigentlich zu heiß dafür die schwarzen löcher haben sie durch ihre gravitation er so
komprimiert
die gestirne bilden konnten zitat diese studie macht sich zum anliegen verschiedene ideen und beobachtungen zusammen zu bringen und zu untersuchen
wie gut sie zusammenpassen und sie passen überraschend gut das sagt pesch linz gibt
zitat wenn das alles korrekt ist dann sind alle galaxien
eingeschlossen unsere eigenen in eine gewaltige sphäre von schwarzen löcher eingebettet von denen jedes rund 30 mal massereicher
ist als die sonne die größten schwarzen löcher und die durch das verschmelzen von schwarzen löchern entstanden sind haben dann
materie um sich gesammelt und so die galaxien gebildet und die ersten gravitationswellen
schienen auch in diese richtung zu deuten so große schwarze löcher galten bis dato als extrem unwahrscheinlich
wenn es also solche schwarzen löcher gebe
könnten sie die dunkle materie erklären und damit wäre das seltsame verhalten der galaxien erklärt man bräuchte keine neuen
elementarteilchen keine neuen oder modifizierten gesetze der gravitation alles wäre prima wenn
tja wenn es da nicht eine neue studie gebe und die haut jetzt alles auseinander
miguel zumal nach peru
und oberzell young ich hoffe ich das richtig ausgesprochen von der university of california in berkeley haben nämlich auf eine etwas ungewöhnliche
methode nach schwarzen löchern gesucht sie haben sich 1300
supernovae des typs 1a vorgenommen sie entstehen durch die gleichen
astrophysikalischen effekte und haben deshalb immer die gleiche helligkeit würde jetzt ein schwarzes loch vorbeiziehen würde es eine
gravitationslinsen bilden und das leuchten würde heller aber pustekuchen
in
keinem fall konnten sie das feststellen wenn die dunkle materie aus schwarzen löchern bestehen würde müsste das in dem ein oder anderen fall passieren
nur wenn es zu wenige schwarze löcher gibt und wenn sie damit auch nicht die dunkle materie erklären
dann würde man das phänomen nicht feststellen sie sagen schwarzer löcher
könnten das phänomen der dunkle materie so maximal nur zu 40 prozent erklären tja
schade oder auch nicht vielleicht ist diese spur ja gar nicht so falsch vielleicht sind es ja verschiedene phänomene die zum effekt einer
vermeintlichen dunklen materie führen wir können gespannt sein was da noch so alles
herauskommen wird wenn er als erstes neues zur dunklen materie zu allen anderen dem erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer ihr
whats app dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau glocke vergessen und hier gehts weiter also darunter dafür auch draufklicken dunkle materie gefunden ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran